From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
My name is David Plylar,
I'm with the Music Division
and I'm going to
be speaking today
about some very special
pieces from late Liszt.
The historical Hungarian poets,
i'm sorry the historical
Hungarian portraits,
involves some poetry so
thats maybe the causes
of that slip there.
It's also know as
the [inaudible],
these pieces were not published
during Liszt life time,
in fact they were not published
at all until 1956 and then 57
and 58 and other parts
of it came to be.
The Library of Congress has
5 sources, sets of sources
of materials for these
pieces and they reside
in the Rosenwald collection
and in the Waters collection.
Its interesting because
the creators
of the new Liszt edition
from Musica Budapest listed
as a secondary source but
there seems to be quite a bit
of primary source material
located in these items.
And after this talk, I'll show
you some of those items if you'd
like up here on the stage.
I pulled them up for you.
The idea behind these pieces
is something of a memorial
to a major Hungarian
figures, both political
and writers and musicians.
And I'd like to read from
somebody who sums it up well
and plays a pivotal
roll in the order
in which I put these
pieces, named [Lagoni?]
He writes: The character
of Széchenyi who's the first
piece, is proud and determined,
unyielding, adimately
persevering, consummating,
making its way firmly,
higher and higher,
you'll actually hear
this in the music.
It is here that the
cycle becomes more tense.
Deák, which he places
as the second piece,
reflects a basically
sunny personality,
who brings about with
great creative force,
a reconciled world around him.
In parentheses "how many
yarns he had once spun,
with how many cheering
turns to them".
And by this he wins his victory.
The piece contains no
tonal funeral music at all,
it is here that the cycle
is given some relief.
So there's tension, relief.
The tragic fate of Teleki, who
he's placing as the third piece,
is an absolutely gripping dead
march above the booming of bells
in the [bostoottoenoto?],
which we'll talk about.
It presents the upmost dramatic
contrast up to the serenity
of the Deák movement.
Eötvös, the movement that
follows Teleki, pays respect
to the man of dynamism in
its prelude and postlude,
and within this framework Liszt
recalls him in this nostalgic,
nocturne sentiments that
lack any funeralial flavor.
This is again followed
by an increase in tension
in the cycle, [inaudible], and
that opens with lonesome leads
of fourths and fifths, and
we'll talk about that as well,
pointing afar and replete with
pain, before the appearance
of a reference to the poet
in the melody of two lines
of his [sosotte?]
above the tolling
of the f sharp [autonatto?]
in the base.
The words being quoted there
is " the wide world holds
for you no other
place than this".
It ends with a string
but increasing clouded
closing section.
I'll skip ahead.
Vörösmarty is replete with
tension, Petõfi brings relief
but in a highly complex way.
Instead of being
a character sketch
of the poet's personality,
it is an image developed
by Liszt himself of the
poet who died so young
on the battlefield,
leaving no trace.
Perhaps for this reason, it's
the portrait in the cycle
with the most facets,
solitary in the prelude,
elegiac in the principle
section but unfolds
out of this solitude,
consoled in the trio,
passionate in the
very recapitulation
of the principle
section and petering
out into the distance
of the postlude.
The last movement brings
profound and mournful grief,
and again this is not a likeness
of Mosonyi but the memory
of him, as the case in
Petõfi's portrait.
So that's kind of a nutshell
of the types of elegies
that are found in this
collection of seven works.
But what that doesn't
necessarily get
across is the depth as is
typical of Liszt that he puts
into each particular piece, not
necessarily aligning very firmly
with a particular
character trait that one
by now might have forgotten,
but rather something
of substance itself
within each piece.
And then he also constructs
something much more,
kind of convoluted
across all seven pieces.
And this is one of the
reasons that we're looking
at these pieces in
this particular order.
I'm going to play these
pieces but I'm going
to explain a little bit
about each one before I do
in a new order rather
one that was proposed
in 1986 or so by [Lagoni?].
And the reason that
their brought about,
why they were published
in the first place
in the wrong order is that
they were in the possession
of August [Guric?] who was a
student of Liszt and who was one
of the people whose
notes we used
about hit the master classes
at the end of Liszt's life
to learn a bit about what he
was doing and what he was up to.
But in any case, they weren't
published for a long time,
eventually the order
just got jumbled
but there is some evidence
in Liszt's letters,
that he had a very
specific order in mind and I
in fact even think that
there's a particular piece
that sets the precedent for
the work as a whole in terms
of how particular motives
are going to be used.
And I'll mention that
when we get to that piece.
Five of the works
were composed in 1885.
Two of them are slight
adaptations slash recompositions
of two earlier pieces,
one from 1870ish,
1871 called Mosonyi's
[inaudible],
which is the funeral procession
of the composer Mosonyi,
I'll speak a little
more about soon.
And the other one is based on,
originally had the name
[inaudible] Petõfi,
and that was basically to
the memory of Petõfi,
who is this major
poet who died in 1849.
And you'll notice a lot
of these people were part
of this revolutionary
struggle in Hungary
and of particular importance
in the revolutionary years
and also post, in trying
to produce the government
and preserve Hungarian
culture and things like that.
Every single one of these people
though is dead by the time
that Liszt writes these pieces
so they are memorial works.
I'm going to not get up and down
so much because of a little bit
of a back problem so
I'm going to speak
from the reminder there
if you don't mind.
Whilst looking at these
pieces in more detail.
So the first piece that
we're going to look
at is called "István
Széchenyi".
And Széchenyi was a major
politician and writer
who was very important
to everybody
and had a very significant
impact in particular on Mosonyi
which we'll get to later
because of his suicide in 1860.
It basically caused a
day of morning in Hungary
and Mosonyi responded with
a very intense funeral work
that actually ended
up catapulting him
to fame in a sense.
We'll speak about
that in a minute
because that piece actually
relates very directly
to a different one
of the Hungarians
that we're going
to be looking at.
One of the things though
that I want to focus on,
is not so much Hungarian history
and Liszt ability to capture
that or capture a character
in a particularly concise way,
even though that is a part
of what these pieces are
but rather I want to show some
of their shared components
and also some of the
alternative versions that exists
in the Library of Congress
manuscripts that we have.
And I'll explain why
some of these, I think,
should actually be considered
to be the primary
versions of the piece.
I can't know for sure.
The the version that was used
on to produce the main
published edition is lost.
So we don't have access to
that manuscript material
but at least we do have some
very compelling evidence
in our own collection which I
think is exciting to look at.
It always makes for
an interesting,
you know, look at these pieces.
So as an example, I'm going play
how Liszt originally had this
in the copyist manuscript.
He has this tendency
to use expository second
statements of an idea.
So put out one idea, repeat it,
then do another idea
and repeat it.
This is how it was originally.
[Music]
So you can hear how those
things are just a repeated idea.
We have Liszt corrections
in-between the staves
so you can see where he
crosses out that secondary idea.
[Music]
He crosses that out and
instead gives us this.
[Music]
That particular idea
is an important one
across the set as well.
And I think that's something
that I'll get to in a minute
about the types of motives that
you'll find in this whole work.
I do want to say that
also what we do find
in this original copyist
manuscript is a simplified
version of the piece,
so we'll have an idea,
I'll play how it was
originally written
and then how Liszt amended it.
[Music]
So he basically creates a little
bit of a rhythmic complexity
and that comes into place,
into play every time we hear
this material in a different way
and it actually serves to
propel the music forward
in an interesting way.
With respect to certain ideas,
that I'm just going to bring
up now that you're going
to hear over and over again
in this entire set and
what's makes the argument
for considering it a cycle
to be a compelling one,
are what I've been
calling fifths and sixths,
they've been recognized
as having the following
fifth motive,
but six played just
an important a roll,
melodically and harmonically.
We'll see them mostly
harmonically here,
or sorry, melodically here.
But then the other
thing to notice is
that all this is very
barren octave laden writing.
It's very exposed,
that in itself is kind
of a motivic idea.
Then we have certain
types of scales
that keep coming back
in a particular way.
I won't go over those right now
but you'll hear them
very clearly.
And also a compelling thing to
think about is these fifth ideas
and sixth ideas were added
after the copyist
version that we have.
So originally it would have,
I'll play what it would have
sounded like, going into,
without the fifths included and
then I'll play just a little bit
of what it sounds
like with the fifths.
[Music]
That's the Tristan cord.
Sorry that's just a
little inside joke there.
But, here's what it sounds
like with the addition
of the material that
was added later.
[Music]
So the fifths, [music]
and the sixths, [music].
I'm not sure if that's [music].
The harmonic context
is not yet clear.
It becomes clear in different
ways and at different points
but it's also highly mobil
and it depends on what type
of voice leading he's using as
to where he wants you to go.
But he also often leaves it very
unclear as to what's happening.
The last thing I'll show you
before I perform the piece is
that he originally had
a different ending,
an entirely different ending.
That just, all it does is
affirm D major like crazy.
So heres that.
[Music]
So in my opinion and
Liszt's I think as well,
not the most compelling ending.
So instead what he does is he
goes back and utilizes some
of the earlier added
material and some
of the introductory
material for this movement
as a way of closing it off.
But he also it does
not end it in D major.
You'll hear how he ends it.
So I'll play this now.
This is ah, ah "István
Széchenyi"
[Music]
So you notice at the end
there it's definitely not
in [music] in D major.
It's actually quiet some,
somewhere quite distant.
And what's also interesting
about and you can see this
in the Library's
manuscript is that Liszt puts
in an indication for trumpets.
So he's already thinking about
orchestrating them at this time.
He does, he doesn't end
up, he puts in instructions
for Széchenyi and
Deák but he doesn't end
up doing the orchestration
himself.
A student of his, named Arthur
Friedhiem also ended up doing,
I think, four of the pieces.
I believe that Liszt heard
those before he passed away the
following year.
But I'm going to move on to the
next piece which is Franz Deák.
And we do not have
any source material
for that particular piece at
the Library but you can hear,
and I'll just point
out a couple of things
and then I'll just play it.
You can hear these fifths
and sixths very clearly.
You'll also hear scale elements,
and also the barren octaves.
THere's also a kind of a
secondary idea, that I think
of as a modified arpeggio that
ends up coming back in a big way
at the very end of the piece
but I'll mention it
again at that point.
So I'll just go ahead
and play it just listen
for these very clear fifths
and sixths motive ideas
that are going to be there at
the beginning of the piece.
[Music]
So why to I hear that as
being quite so unclouded
as the commentator I
first read from in terms
of where that piece goes.
One might hear what might be
typically called Hungarianish
sounding things because of
the use of particular scales
that particularly emphasize
an augmented second.
To completely oversimplify it.
But then we move on to a new
area that involves Mosonyi,
Széchenyi, the first piece
and Teleki, who is the,
the third portrait of
that particular person.
As mentioned earlier
Széchenyi committed suicide
and stunned everybody
and Mosonyi, the story is
within a few days he
wrote this as a response.
I'm not going to play the whole
piece because it's a big piece
but Im going to play a
relevant little chunk,
and what I want you
to particularly listen
to the baseline.
[Music]
So in that baseline we
have the seed for what
in 1885 Liszt would turn
into his [inaudible]
and [inaudible] march
and this march
in particular uses
this base and its
from this particular
[inaudible] funeral march
that he develops
the Teleki portrait
in the historical
Hungarian portraits.
He makes certain modifications
to it that you can see at,
on our manuscripts so Liszt is
modifying copyist manuscripts
that we have.
But I want to show you how the
[inaudible] leads into the march
and it helps to explain some
of the changes that he made.
So here's the original funeral
prelude and march that were
for August Guric that ended
up taking the historical
Hungarian portraits
to the next level.
[Music]
So that's how he gets in to it
and you might have noticed my
little mistake there that's
because I was playing
the version
that Liszt changed it to.
What we have is a very
strange emphasis of C sharp
which is basically the front
end and back end of the scale.
Is what the [inaudible]
prelude consists of.
I think I'm going to skip
this other demonstration
from the [inaudible] march
because it's basically
the same piece as Teleki
but it's just a bit longer.
And the way that Liszt
ended up tightening it up is
by extending the
period we have just
on the strong beat statement
of the base austonoto pattern.
And then eventually it picks
up steam and moves forward.
It's just a little bit
more tightly constructed
than the, than the other piece.
There is something that's really
interesting in our manuscript
that I just want to mention
about here that is missing
from the published version.
And that's this amazing
moment where he marks esposivo
in the midst of a
fortissimo passage.
And its, what's amazing about
it to me and it may just be me,
is that, that's how
I would think of it
when I got there even though
it's very dark and heavy.
The other thing that
stands as a difference
between these other pieces is
that the funeral march
version is all staccato.
There's a lot of piano
in the Teleki movement.
So I'm just going to
grab a sip of water
and play the Teleki movement.
[Music]
So one thing to notice at
the very end of this is
that we have isolated
[music] the fifth, [music]
and the minor, the major sixth
which in the context
sounds minor
because of , it sounds
G minorish.
But this piece proceeds
the other ones
and may well be the seed
for identifying [music],
identifying that
as motivic material
for the rest of the entire work.
Moving past Teleki, we
get to József Eötvös.
You might know there's
currently a living conductor
and composer with that name.
I don't know if there's a
relationship but in any case,
for our purposes what
we get here is more
of those open fifths, and we get
a very clear harmonic setting
of the fifths and sixths.
And heres what that fifths
and sixths sound like here.
[Music]
So in this case the outlines
[music] fifths, [music] sixths,
and they'll be outlined
more clearly
when I actually play the piece.
Let's see if I have
anything else about this.
One other thing just to look
for are, are also reoccurrences
of these open scales and
empty octaves, especially
and the end of the
first section.
So this is in three sections,
a very beautiful piece.
[Music]
So Liszt very carefully
coordinated these particular
light cues to happen during
the course of that work
and was just pulled
off brilliantly there.
But unfortunately he didn't do
that for the rest of the pieces.
Well, or fortunately for me.
Hopefully for me.
The next piece, I'm just
gonna keep moving right along.
Honors Mihály Vörösmarty,
and he is a poet best know
for his setting of the
Hungarian appeal, sorry,
the penning of the
Hungarian appeal.
Which was then set
by [inaudible] later
and became something
of a national anthem.
And here's a case where I
think that we have evidence
in our collection of
a different opening
that should be there
based on the fact
that Liszt has crossed out, or
actually covered up and written
on top of the published version.
So uh, there's something
very interesting here.
Here's way it goes in
the published version
and when I actually play it
I'll play the new version that's
based on the Library's material.
[Music]
So what we have are very
clear open fifths, fourths,
very much in line with
that motivic continuity.
But Liszt ended up adding
a scaler component to it
which I'll play in
just a minute.
Another important thing
to point out about
in this particular piece
is that it includes a quote
from that [inaudible] piece.
Liszt even writes in
Vörösmarty wrote this,
meaning that he penned
the lyrics to it.
It's a little bit, it's just
a tiny fragment of the theme.
It actually comes from later
in the movements,
rather in the appeal.
So it's not necessarily
an obvious thing except
that the rhymic material
feels very familiar.
It also happens to have
in-versional relationships
to that original appeal.
It turns out the the Library
also has Liszt piano version
of this, the [inaudible] which
is a combination of two pieces
that it was originally
for orchestra.
The, I think there were
some singers involved too
and there's different
versions of all these.
And he made this solo
piano version as well
which the Library has.
There's that and then there's
one other thing I wanted
to mention and that's
in all these pieces there are
some real questionable tempos.
And part of the issue is that,
you have copyist who will write
for instance in quarter
note equals 84
or something like that.
And then you'll have presumably
Liszt going in with a blue crown
and putting it in to
cut time after the fact.
So it becomes a question of
what exactly is the beat,
is it going to be the
larger beat or is it going
to be the smaller one.
To me the music makes fairly
clear that it is the larger beat
so that music ends up going
faster because of this.
Otherwise I think it
would just go to slow
for what the material merits.
So here is Vörösmarty.
[Music]
You can hear all those exposed
octaves still very much around.
And another strange
ending to the work
in a very different
place from what seemed
like a B minorish [music]
or maybe a B majorish start
to something [music]
in the G ish region.
But with, without enough
pitches to make it very clear.
The penultament work
in this set,
the Library has a version
called [inaudible] Petõfi's
of that earlier piece
from about 1877
that Liszt has corrected
and made changes to.
So he puts into there places
where he wants a
measure repeated twice
or something like that.
And then he gives a whole
bunch of different endings.
And because of the way he
puts together these endings,
which I'll play for
you shortly just
so you can hear what
the differences are,
it makes me think
that the final version
that got published is
actually probably incorrect
because of the particular
profile and a character
of the progression that
he's using at the end .
So I'll play my corrected
version for you.
The material itself though
is related to Petõfi but in
that it pulls from an
earlier tradition called
"the recitation" in which you
have a piano accompanying a
dramatic reading of a work.
And so in 1874, Liszt did this
with a Hungarian poem of a story
by [inaudible], I think I'm
probably not pronouncing
that right, which was
ostensibly about Petõfi
who again had been this major
national hero who disappeared
on the battlefield,
presumably dead but nobody heard
from him again and
actually yoky later wrote
about if he had lived.
That's sorta an alternate
reality sorta senerio.
But what we have in this work
that basically translates
into the dead poet's love.
You have this very
clear motto theme
that gets associated
with Petõfi.
I'm going to play a
little bit from that
so you can hear that
motto theme.
Here it is in the
original resertation.
[Music]
So you hear an extended version
of that in [inaudible] Petõfi.
In fact it starts with this,
up a half step [music].
It starts that way with
[inaudible] Petõfi's.
Later Liszt would actually
expand the opening,
in the Library of Congress
expansion it's by 8 measures
and the version that
got published
that I think is probably
correct is ten measures.
Correct because of that
double expository component
that present in most of Liszt's
work as I mentioned before.
THere's also this other idea
that comes into play that's kind
of etherial type of music.
And here's what that
sounds like.
[Music]
So that will appear in
the Petõfi as well.
Then Liszt does what
you'd expect.
He develops this idea,
always presenting it
in a moderate type form.
But I just want to give you a
couple of what, how he decided
to set it because he does
not do that in Petõfi
where he could have
chosen to do it.
[Music]
And now listen to what we
have in those upper parts,
you're gonna have those
fifths and sixths.
[Music]
So he's very much moving into
a Straussian kind of world.
And here are just two
more quick examples.
[Music]
And lastly a final development.
And I played it through
till there
because this idea [music]
is used very promenately
in Petõfi which I'll play now.
But also in a very
different way.
So he similtanisouly
expands the music and kind
of redirects the
dramatic content
of the original resertation
into this new setting.
But before I start it I forgot
to mention the new endings,
I should just show you quickly.
So originally and the end
of [inaudible] Petõfi's
it ends like this.
[Music]
The next version that was wrote
but then was crossed
out goes like this.
I'm playing it a
little bit faster
that you would play it normally.
[Music]
He's not happy with that
so he goes on and some
of this is illegible so
I'm just kind of filling
in what I think is
suppose to be there.
[Music]
Crosses that out.
Then he moves on to
say I think I need
to incorporate the Petõfi
motif though he does this
and this is really hard to read
so I'm just kind of guessing.
[Music]
It breaks off there so he's
trying to think of a way
to incorporate the melody
but it's not working.
So in the published version
what we have is this kind
of a [music], that's the
progression that gets put
in there but the chords
are out of order according
to every single one of
these other examples.
And in fact the one
that is not crossed
out by Liszt has
a different order.
And that is [music].
And so that's the one
I'm going to play.
It's just two chords
switched around
but it makes a big difference
and it make [inaudible]
perspective.
So here's Petõfi's.
[Music]
So Liszt's solution ends up
being the most kind of exposed
and like but also the
most poetic I think
as a solution just to set
that [inaudible] theme
by itself at the very end.
And I think it's a very
beautiful solution.
Again we end up in C sharp
major, who knows where we came
from but it's a very
kind of bold thing to do.
We then move on to
the last piece
which you might have heard
before in a version known
as Mosonyi's [inaudible].
It's a funeral procession.
Mosonyi I said came into
prominence more or less
in the late 1850s
and into 1860s.
Originally his name was Michal
Braun but he decided to go
by Mosonyi to kind
of show solidarity
with the Hungarian cause.
So this particular one
was written in 1870,
kind of the earliest of the set
and was Liszt's response
to Mosonyi death.
He was one of Liszt great
compositional friends.
So in edition to this
being a great elegy,
it serves as the capstone
for the entire set
of the historical
Hungarian poets.
But what's interesting, in
particular what I'm going
to do today, is that I'm
going to play a version
that shows corrections and
additions in Liszt's hand.
It came to us in the
Ed Waters collection.
This is a very strange ending.
All those things I've been
talking about, those fifths
and sixths open octaves,
ah scaler components,
seconds moving this way and that
in a rhymically clear fashion.
But it was also something that
Liszt clearly struggled with.
In fact I'll just play through
a sped up version of a couple
of those endings right now
for you so you can hear
where he's starting with.
It's suppose to end,
at least according
to the original in D major.
[Music]
He does provide some
alternatives
where it involves this [music].
Ultimately he ends it
in a very different way.
So I'm just going to play
through it so you can hear it
and it's a striking
difference and I'm curious
to see afterwards if anybody
wants to stick around and talk
to me and look at
the manuscripts.
See what you think about it.
I'm not sure that it's
Liszt's last word on it.
It certainly seems like it's
the last one that we have.
But he was prone to
a lot of revision
and different version
of the pieces.
So it would have
been interesting
to see what would have happened
had gone through the press.
It might have made
other difference too
in the rest of the piece.
So here is Mihály Mosonyi.
[Music]
So that's the way Liszt
edited it in this case.
So thank you all for being here
and going through these with me.
I think there's a good reason
to have an edition made
that incorporates the
Library's manuscripts.
That would be fantastic
because I think some
of the differences make it
tie better together as a set.
Also just work differently
musically.
Liszt's versions of his
own pieces often have a
separate identity.
It's not necessary a question of
if one is better than the other
but it's just a different way
of looking at the same material.
It's always a kind of exciting
thing to be able to look
at this music and learn from it.
So thanks again for coming.
[Applause]
This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at LOC.gov